[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
ALI: Hi, everyone.
I'm Ali, working for the Google
Drive team, and today
we're going to show you how to
write a complete JavaScript
browser-based Google Drive
app, hopefully
in under five minutes.
It's going to take a bit of copy
and paste, but I'm going
to take you through each of
the individual steps.
Now the first thing I
want to show you is
our QuickStart page.
Now, we have a QuickStart page
for how to get up and running
quickly in one of Java,
Python, PHP.Net, Ruby,
JavaScript, and Go.
So today we're going
to be going through
the JavaScript one.
So that's developers.googl
e.com/drive/quickstart.
So the first step in writing
any application is to go to
the Google API's console and
create an API project.
So I'm just going to click on
Create Project, and it's going
to do most of the
magic for me.
So as you can see, it's created
a project for me, and
I have to choose which Google
services it's going to use.
So I scroll down here and I
see Drive API, and I just
switch that on.
So you see this selector has
gone to on, and now I can
start using the Drive API.
So what I have to do is
create a client ID.
Create a client that is
suitable for use as a
browser-based client.
So you see it's already created
a simple API access
one for me.
But this big blue button, Create
An OAuth 2.0 Client, we
click on that and I
give it a name--
JS Quick Start.
And as you can see, it's
a web application.
Now one thing I have to really
make sure I do correctly here
is set up an origin.
Because I'm going to be testing
this on localhost and
it will be on Port 8000.
So I just need to set that up
so that it knows, when it's
running JavaScript code, that
it's running in the correct
container, and that's
just a check.
So I create that client ID.
And I'll leave that there
because, as you see, we're
going to come back to this when
we need the client ID
that's there.
As you can see, the JavaScript
Origin HTTPS localhost 8000 is
what I've set up there.
So now on to the code.
Now, our QuickStart page has
copy, pastable code that you
should be able to just copy,
paste and run, so that's
exactly what I'm going to do.
Obviously it would take you
more than five minutes to
write all this code.
But the idea is that once you've
got it running, you
really then can modify
it however you like.
So I'm going to take a copy of
that, and I'm going to put it
in my directory in a file
called index.html.
Start in Editor, paste my code
in, and there it is.
It's all collapsed, but as you
can see it's in JavaScript
embedded in some HTML.
Obviously, as you get more
detailed in your application
you might want to take
that out into
separate JavaScript files.
Now the one part I need to
change is here where
it says client ID.
And that's the client ID
that I just created
here in the API console.
So I'll copy that in,
and there it is.
Now, those of you who have used
OAuth before, you might
be wondering why do I not
use a client secret?
Well, client secrets are
not really secret if
they're in a web page.
Obviously anyone can examine the
source, so for that reason
there's no point in having it.
So the web-based protocol only
requires a client ID.
So once I've done that, I save
it and I'm back to my shell.
Now here where I need to run a
local web server just to get
it up and running, I use Python
SimpleHTTPServer.
Now, you can run Python with
the minus M flag, and that
just starts the server, in
this case, on Port 8000.
So once I've got that there,
then I can browse localhost
8000 and see what happens.
Now this is a very simple
application.
All it does is upload
a single file.
But first thing I get is a
pop-up to request permission.
Make sure that pop-ups are
allowed for your localhost,
because that would
get blocked.
The reason is this QuickStart,
the pop-up doesn't come in
response to a button or
anything like that.
So by default, Chrome and other
browsers will block that.
But when you're writing your
application, probably you'd
put this behind a button,
click this to authorize.
So I authorize there, and when
I refresh my page you see--
and we'll open the
API console--
you'll see I've got a
Choose File button.
So this is the entire user
interface for this
application.
I select a file, as you
can see nicely here.
I've got some images ready--
and that was
an image of a dog.
And the only feedback you get
currently is in console.log.
And you can see that the entire
metadata for the file
has been returned back here.
So you may not be able to see
that, but for example, the
bits I set--
the title, the alternate
link, various
information about that.
The title is actually
the file name.
And it will have done some other
cool things like MD5
checks on it for you.
It's correctly identified
the MIME type.
So now if I look in my Google
Drive, I can see that that
file has now magically
appeared--
0.JPG.
And I look at that, and it's
a beautiful picture of my
neighbor's dog.
And there you go.
That is in entirety us having
written a Drive app.
Should we try another one?
Why not?
We'll go for the same file, the
other images I've got are
a bit big, but that
will upload.
Maybe we should have called it a
day at writing a single one.
So where do we want
to go from here?
Well, unfortunately the
JavaScript integration is not
exactly perfect.
If you have a look through some
of that code, some of it
is a bit nasty.
And the reason for that is we
don't have full support for
all the types of media outplay
that we do for the other
client libraries.
So for JavaScript's case, what
we're actually doing is
manually creating a multi-part
request.
And you can see the code there
on the screen, and please have
a look at it.
It's fairly nasty--
you have to create the
multi-part yourself, you have
to create the boundaries, you
have to encode into Base64 the
various parts.
And when that's done, it will
operate successfully.
So what I suggest you do here
is just copy and paste that
code, put it out
on a function.
And pretend that it's not
happening like that until we
get the complete different
types of upload.
For example, resumable
upload working in
JavaScript in the library.
So that's JavaScript.
Hopefully, I've shown you that
you can write a complete
application for Google
Drive in the browser.
Now we have no service
[? like ?] work.
It was completely a StaticHTML
page, and I'm serving it using
just a plain web server.
Please go and check those out.
This video will be part
of that guide.
And if you're interested in
other languages, we have
videos for all the other
languages there.
But I really recommend you try
this JavaScript support.
It's so strong to be able to
have this application that
doesn't rely on any backend
framework, or
anything like that.
Anyone can run it, anyone can
add new functionality, so
that's pretty cool.
OK, thank you very much.
I've been Ali.
Enjoy yourselves.
And good luck with your Google
Drive integrations.
[MUSIC PLAYING]